un terrible exemple derrière le moins
remarqué quoi vous de monaco merci et
quoique lemoine c'est une ville mais non
c'était le club s'il m'avait offert des
cas qui me l'avait offert à bien à
l'époque où je faisais mon olympien donc
c'est un sentimental
voilà également jean-luc on a une
question voilà parce qu'on s'en fout de
mes anecdotes bonjour je m'appelle jean
claude j'ai l'impression qu'à partir du
mal
nos chroniqueurs ne savent pas faire
grand chose donc je voulais savoir
qu'est ce qu'il compte faire après tpm
pc gros crétin je vous remercie pour
cette question mesure est cher
jean-claude mais excusez moi de vous
reprendre nous ne sommes pas tous gros
seins et pour vous répondre ça c'est que
contrairement aux idées reçues ils ont
tous une vie et une activité ont
d'intégré tmp une activité comprend
raisonnement reprendre si l'émission
s'arrêter à savoir chômeurs en fait le
seul qui s'en sortir à si l'émission
s'arrête c'est cyril 1 bat déjà parce
qu'il a plus d'argent que nous et aussi
parce qu'il a tous les talents
est ce que vous saviez par exemple que
cyril avaient un point commun avec
isabelle morini bosc
non les anecdotes et je parle pas de la
taille de la poitrine je savais pas il
est portraitiste non alba
je vais vous révéler un secret
[Musique]
mais
bougez pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'attendait
juste comme ça
5e journée
[Musique]
c'est une fusée sa capture vous l'avez
bien mérité votre entrée au patrimoine
de l'unesco cia c'est le tour de magie
si vous voulez je vous passerais la
semaine prochaine au tour de magie
trouve pas mon meilleur épiceries des
créatifs ans récemment il a inventé une
nouvelle rubrique le quart d'heure sans
filtre alors si vous connaissez pas
encore cette rubrique
si vous explique le principe le quart
d'heure sans filtre michel drucker donc
tac laurent delahousse at il tort ou
raison
on y va en paix lancé le chrono les
chéris on va parler trois minutes de ces
deux et non oui c'est le quart d'heure
sans fitia cinq minutes vraiment là
parce qu'on a eu tout étudié cinq
minutes vous devez être sans filtre
voilà c'est simple vous devez être sans
fil pendant un quart d'heure qui dure
entre trois et cinq minutes comme le 23
45 de camille combal
1 les chiffres sont donnés à titre
indicatif battant l'émission sera
présentée par autre chose qu'un tunisien
m'a peut-être que ce sera car et du
match ou alors il faut que je vous dise
comme cette rubrique dit lis pas mal
ah oui beaucoup l'adorent mais certains
se plaignent notamment à cause du risque
de crises d'épilepsie qui peut survenir
pendant le débat parce qu'il ya ce qu'on
raconte sur le plateau mais surtout ce
qui est diffusé à l'antenne des coûts et
en regardant l'émission en fait ce qu'on
se rend pas compte ici vous avez déjà
regardé l'émission
ouais ouais les gars d'ailleurs on les
arrête on l'est on les arrête pas là ni
vous êtes aujourd'hui aller voir un
niveau et les spéciaux on n'avait pas
fait plus chargée depuis les réseaux
l'est de l'île de la tentation et son
tour d'horizon tout miser des éclairs
des images qui sautent des zooms
intempestif du mange ta soupe ou
regardant l'émission est obligé de le
renverser
excusez moi c'est quand même on est
quand même la seule émission où il ya un
cadreur il ya une 4e qui parle d'un gars
mais tranquille quoi ça va et sinon tu
vas la nasa doug edwards
on arrive à nous tenir à l'écart
réactions en bord de seine tranquille
alors tu vas nous faire quoi pour moi et
je vais penser oh ça on va se réunir ou
à la ferme comment une table de ping
pong normalement allez on regarde ce qui
se passe pour un quart d'heure sans fil
[Musique]
je crois que la magnifique mans grand
pour son rôle dans sa vie mais un jour
je trouve qu'elle distribue en fait
[Musique]
c'est aussi un peu de notre faute et
puis on a mis les voiles et ken pâques
une meuf qu'à 43 ans ont lu des pékin
qu'elle vienne car ça promet kapisa et
qu'elle rend pas nos pieds
[Musique]
justement pendant les auditions et là on
va les voir justement les a pas mal donc
c'est très bizarre
directe en demi-finale c'est un peu
curieux on va lever le pied la cfdt pour
tous alors c'est compliqué de faire un
bon débat le seul qui ne doute jamais de
ses interventions
c'est jean michel maire regardez sont
des pics en syrie n'est pas d'accord
avec lui et puis mathieu les gens se
goinfrent à longueur de journée de
séries américaines de flics et à leur
monde des vrais flics et cetera c'est
comme ça va rien à voir c'est plus
intéressant de voir la vraie vie je suis
pas sûre de cette intervention
[Rires]
j'ai trouvé le bild évoque alors michel
qui vous l'aurez remarqué et soient
ainsi de ce côté là maintenant car cette
année il faut savoir qu'ils se partagent
la garde isabelle mathieu dandenault ce
qui vient c'est peut-être mon magnéto
préfet la semaine franchement c'est une
réussite parce que au début j'étais pas
convaincu j'avais peur que mathieu
maltraite isabelle mais en fait pas du
tout à se réduire en hommage est ce que
très bien d'elle a même si on a
l'impression s'adresse à une vieille
dame sénile merci beaucoup
c'est grégoire ou non ces séquences
auraient pu avoir sa place dans le top
gênante mais non cette semaine j'avais
d'autres choses pour moi mm p vous le
savez depuis longtemps et qui sait
voilà des années qu'on chérit camille
nous la dernière fois que vous êtes venu
nous voir
[Musique]
vous êtes excepté les croisés c'est 3
milliards de stream dans le monde
lang
allez
moi je
[Musique]
benjamin est une star on a nommé je l'aï
l'état et il est généreux les
différences vont tuer ça que j'ai été
numéro 1 et j'écris des numéros 2 mais
toi tu seras jamais numéro 1 0 j'aime
bien c'est qu'ils sont tellement sur
leur égo les deux là c'est que ce qui je
crois c'est s'équiper port restants
[Rires]
allez dire que je suis je me dois crise
je pense que benjamin est déjà revenu et
une gloire et vous vous allez être
numéro 1 très vite également à daniel
donc tout misé plus quand même sur moi
comme çà mau et où les deux hommes de
massimo moi oui honnêtement pour moi
vous êtes vous êtes parti pour être dans
le top 20 huawei non les deux mois les
deux hommes disent non non à l'est de
top 20 mais pas du graff le top 50 ans
dans le top 10 ce temps mais si vous
allez vous préparer de belles choses
pour ces vite à ton départ
[Rires]
mais un petit billet tu mets sur wam sur
écoute et ne parlons pas de choses qui
fâchent on y va la meilleure vente de la
semaine maintenant on la doit à siri pas
cyril hanouna non siri l'assistant vocal
des iphone ah oui et notamment celui de
rokhaya diallo qui avait oublié de
l'éteindre pendant l'émission
résultat quand maxime gainey ainsi de
prononcer les noms de et sheeran syrie a
résumé tout ce que tout le monde pensait
tout bas seront opposés de dire vendredi
16 décembre s'est engueulé paraître chez
ralph le samedi ça sera quoi dîner
paraître sheeran a inauguré on ne
comprend pas cette personne et même
syrie le dit assez ri à tort car maxime
est un bosseur et pour le prouver
préfère maintenant quelque chose que je
fais jamais montré des images des
coulisses à des loges le bidon à l'ère
du même nom ouais ouais
car même si maxime n'a pas apporté un
skin valable depuis le 7 janvier
ouais et encore le 7 janvier c'était sa
première sur ce couple s'était j'arrive
dans tpm paix même s'il n'a pas de scoop
maxime bosse vraiment comme le prouvent
ces images fait pas maxime je prépare
mes fiches pour l'émission bonjour
qu'est ce tu travailles et kelly tu fais
quoi les émissions
comme façon aucun kelly vdo bélie qui
est un mystère pour beaucoup
oui oui bah oui mais comment fait-elle
pour être aussi détendu avant l'antenne
télé shampoing utilise tel pour avoir
des cheveux aussi soyeux tel est son
rôle exact dans l'émission pour moi
c'était clair kelis et c'est la djette
un élève à prendre et de la musique est
vrai c'est ce que je pensais mais des
images ont semé le trouble et liv et
deauville il pas elle a fait trois pipes
allait peut-être comme ça alors mais
c'est moi qui a remis son nom mais quand
tu écoutes on t'aime comme ça se trouve
tu es devenu sont bien de la meuf à lui
même plus ce mardi pour faire pencher la
balance de la musique par la pensée lé
dj médium alors honnêtement j'y crois
pas alors j'ai mené mon enquête déjà un
extrait m'a interpellé
nous sommes le 22 novembre 2017 je ne
peux pas envoyer de son abba vas-y dit
le sieur vous m'avez cassé mon
ordinateur de l'eau dessus voilà alors
cyril aurait cassé l'ordinateur de kelly
en envoyant de l'eau dessus
ce qui m'étonne pas ce que c'est pas le
genre de série de jeux avec des liquides
c'était quatre responsables d'équilibré
qui sait que si on rebouche mal une
bouteille et bah ça risque d'éclabousser
non
accès
[Musique]
non
ma conviction a vacillé et si kelly
avait dit la vérité
alors j'ai cherché dans tous les images
et finalement je suis tombé sur ça un
soleil que faut-il retenir de ces images
un que l'eau c'est pas bon pour le
matériel électronique
oui et 2 qu'en france c'est impossible
de faire réparer un ordinateur dans des
délais convenables
parce que ce que je voulais dire c'est
que l'incident en question date du 14
novembre
bon ça fait deux ans qu'il y fait
semblant avec des musiques
ou alors dit que moi ou une fois c'est
vrai c'est un rayon de soleil vient on à
dos rayon de soleil pendant ses clients
notamment on en a maintenant je voulais
dire qu'on en a plein là on a beau
n'avoir que des soleils voilà merci
c'est toujours de bonne humeur tout
sympa ouais non mais c'est vrai c'est
important je vais dire il veut dire la
pécho elle est temps qu'on est dans des
grandes révélations arrivent à un moment
difficile de la rubrique les énigmes et
mystères non résolus les choses qui ont
dû rester secrète voyez de quoi je veux
parler
alors moi j'ai rien annoncer les
dossiers secrets de encore une fois j'ai
appris des choses très surprenante on
décortiquant les off ça concerne les
chroniqueurs ou vous non les
chroniqueurs vous dirai ce que voulaient
que je diffuse ou pas ah bon il peut
passer les sinois alors
moi je prends le risque parce que je
pense que c'est les chroniqueurs
franchement mais aucun secret eh bien
vous avez gagné
ça concerne les chroniqueurs allez on y
va
[Musique]
si bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu n'es pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
carrément
on doit supporter sachez que c'est trop
loin par rapport à nous il est temps de
passer à tous qu'on n'aurait pas voulu
voir et entendre cette semaine qu'il
avait ça déjà fait il y en a encore on
commence par cyril qui nous prouve une
nouvelle fois qu'il maîtrise
parfaitement la langue de shakespeare
[Musique]
faire quand tu étais au lycée de
s'habiller comme ans et je trouve que
dans l'émission il a un truc c'est qu'il
n'est pas langue de bois
mine de rien et benjamins il a encore
une carrière devant lui c'est vraiment
animateurs
est-ce que vous avez vous moi j'ai adoré
j'ai pas trouvé ça en ayant parce que
généralement ces trucs là ils voient ça
m'ennuie
[Applaudissements]
et
tél
[Applaudissements]
documentaire que vous faites
j'aime les belles gifles et c'est parce
qu'il a peur peut-être époux mais t'as
pas de slip
ouais ça c'est quoi des l'offre locaux
du dollar oui alors benjamin
pour ma part je te trouve très cultivé
elle a pour sa part ça va mon pire - si
tu devais partir seul sur une île
déserte avec quelqu'un de l'équipe ce
serait qu une petite question
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or il se met dans des trous mais que tu
pour l'intérêt de l'équipe
c'est pas du tout j'aime bien ça
j'ai l'impression
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai regardé sur le paquet est
actuellement c'est ça la classe et
biffle les deux hommes et à iren mais
les gars franchement les a perdus grâce
est vrai mais à ne pas pas merci
[Applaudissements]